okay well well well it's your Bush
psychobabble here and we are playing man
Oh Madonn this is basically I don't know
if you guys have seen the [ __ ] was that
game with the [ __ ] snow yet either
share the [ __ ] lowest priority but
see that's a new one I can't practice
its interactive game and it is [ __ ]
dope I hear it's [ __ ] dope no one's
barely visible there we go
don't play alone play alone yeah we just
check out the [ __ ] settings [ __ ]
settings wrote them okay
audio and language we got [ __ ]
subtitles hell oh yeah babby yeah we go
we got this we got this dogs yeah of
course I want to save it okay I think it
was a until dog
there's the interactive movie that game
that came out Rami Malek and all that it
was really it look like a movie was
insane and way let's [ __ ] do this
it's like the sequel for a [ __ ]
long-ass night actually this isn't
direct sequel this isn't the same kind
of universe start in the new dark
anthology series and make it official
franchise they also did the impatient
which I think was VR only but still
really good all right it's a dis [ __ ] I
don't know [ __ ] about this all of them
take a haunted ghost ship I think yeah
there it is right there there it is
right there let's [ __ ] do this
no I got one save slots I better pick
this one okay okay and the Sun we are
one
man of Madonna or Maiden I don't know
madam Maiden
i'ma [ __ ] it now I don't [ __ ] know
man the graphics look [ __ ] dope this
guy you could see his he is way too many
productive old glance you know yeah yes
sir sorry i sorry you know
[ __ ] say that so apparently it's just
like until dawn we're like if you [ __ ]
up like [ __ ] characters die and they
[ __ ] stay dead yeah [ __ ] junk
isn't Scott dead talking about that lady
[ __ ] we had a question has the towels up
[ __ ] yeah let's do without me rich wait
what she's a right sugar so am I gonna
hit the jackpot you know all that glitz
and glamour
what indie
dragon top Ava it's [ __ ] bad better
did bamboos retching wealth right look
at the tile
tell me what you say betcha press and
hold to pick up and hard to examine it's
a [ __ ] Marlin looks like a fish
you let go yeah man this ham is looking
good that skin was [ __ ] fortune they
come from a leadership what the [ __ ] I
mean for but he talks slows be told that
my bro
traits and secure selfish reckless
altruistic ok hey ok let me do this
I'll give it a whirl let's do that swirl
baby
yeah what oh what the [ __ ] shit's
wiggling [ __ ] yeah well [ __ ] brought
this bro if I could beat up people every
[ __ ] day I got her back I had fights
am i every [ __ ] day [ __ ] [ __ ] Pro
that [ __ ] uh well she got [ __ ] little
[ __ ]
you're just a little [ __ ] no he's
actually getting angry yeah [ __ ] up
let's go [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
very dirty it's like nighttime because
y'all [ __ ] thirties I know how can
walkie-talkies back then
let's go that's good honey back into the
bowels take your [ __ ] Jurassic Park
with a [ __ ] goat going down the old
leaky the lead oh yeah do this there we
go
USFA [ __ ] you SMA that [ __ ] I thought
there's our [ __ ] soldiers of war they
were their [ __ ] weapons I don't know
just a grand Jack how as always
50 cents
what or Freddie says well what the [ __ ]
is that a sir sure
yeah that's [ __ ] it that is [ __ ]
I'll say that much
[ __ ] shiny
that guy's getting [ __ ] wet
yeah there we go baby
wait what the [ __ ] is that
supernatural [ __ ] right here
you're a pisser
he's going in he's he is going in what
this exam [ __ ] I see this [ __ ] what
yours this
yeah little Steph buttons alright yeah
[ __ ] right just [ __ ] great
oh there's a $0.50 there's a $0.50 right
there
the graphic in here insane
that's a bad don't mind if I do
he greases it agent so much and he got
burned you know
as my son I did tie back to pop
comebacks in Bray and some guy already
look how fast I can go
oh [ __ ] okay there can I guess at the
store
I guess alright it I feel like he's
already passed the whole dead body thing
he's [ __ ] out as long as a he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] felt though dude
the graphics are insane sick [ __ ]
watching a [ __ ] movie that's what you
say
okay wait can I go in there oh [ __ ] he's
like blocking my [ __ ] way [ __ ]
press a in time with the heartbeat okay
well
yeah I'm a [ __ ] professional it's a
bad dude right here though [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] like creamy in son cruise ships
like what the [ __ ] is it
you like that [ __ ] country what was
that nothing [ __ ] keep walking
oh there's a toxic show on the grounds
it
is it safe to go in there let's force
[ __ ] open man to man holy [ __ ] and
[ __ ] sweaty like [ __ ] towel I feel
like [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] up I'm gonna [ __ ]
13 years old I got lights on in here
that's [ __ ] that that is [ __ ]
can I go this way yeah it's alright a
[ __ ] Ron
[ __ ]
yeah that's way here we go okay here we
go
talking took a while to get through this
that was again the back they said that
[ __ ] miss flying right here
oh here we go
I only took ten years
[ __ ] it's stuck look at stack
so
is it just me or are you getting a real
strange feeling right now
I
when I think of these [ __ ] boats in
there holy [ __ ] that won't jump me let's
go [ __ ] got me this goddamn money
that one [ __ ] guy right there I'm
[ __ ] copy [ __ ] dead bodies all
over the place dead
shut up [ __ ]
I don't think this shit's haunted it
just sounds like one was like paranoia
jokes I mice got loose or some [ __ ] like
[ __ ] the Arkham Asylum was it Batman
one with that medicine came out that
like attack thing just gets [ __ ] high
as [ __ ] so yeah looks [ __ ] high as
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] there this is [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] stinking that look at the
one [ __ ] through a fart in there hello
jump-scare [ __ ] jump-scare right here
ready you said that let's say here hold
shoot that [ __ ] shoot that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] only about Charlie's in their
[ __ ] Charlie's in there I know it
that [ __ ] happen this guy is like
[ __ ] his brains out he's not doing
it too hot he's [ __ ] now hey [ __ ] now
well what the [ __ ]
get a sec juror from better awareness
this [ __ ] beer
[Music]
hmm and this nice [ __ ] I kept talking
hanging gallows with the [ __ ] what's are
there
did we like say no music or something
thank you music right here
yeah there should be music right here
yeah what yeah thank you thick thin our
streaming or something they're like yeah
they're like you better cut that
anything out
Thanks pretty handsome I got to tell
this guy man really cleans up his beard
all right Graham Resnick I feel like I
should be talking about now this is
don't [ __ ] music in here
I can't think of Sagres oh man this
[ __ ] that looks great
my trusty pocket watch yeah it's about
that time
Jason great
yeah this guy's like he loves the size
of his house but he hates how much he
has to walk
whoa okay ever you say so
hello Act and welcome to my repository
huh a repository net suppository
that's Candace he got there
I am the curator the curator of stories
Hey greed and beauty live and death
stories such as this one I'm here to
record the story you choose to tell you
see this tale is only part written and
the choices you make will complete it ah
Terman rather the lives of those with
whom you are interfering continue to
flourish snuffed out
you see we each make decisions according
to our own moral compass and we have to
live with those decisions or die by mmm
but you shouldn't fear death it is after
all inevitable does the tax one pays for
having lived and it comes eventually to
everybody in a grave voice none of us
want for it to come too soon do as in
life the actions you take matter the
choices you make will affect others
I'll be keeping a close eye on your
progress it's not my place to interfere
but I might be persuaded to offer the
occasional hint okay
here's one for free there are pictures
in this world that can show you some
possible futures if you can find them
and study them they may just help you to
make better decision Oh
or should I say decisions that result in
the outcomes you would prefer deep
that's all for the moment we'll talk
again soon and is the opportunity to
account for all the actions that you've
taken that sheds tape
okay I'll be the judge of that
uh-huh oh [ __ ] we're [ __ ] going in
Brad Alex's brother innocent present-day
Duke of Milan Alex
Julie's boyfriend may be gone enough if
we run out we can always call for backup
look I've never been down there before
down water diving maybe you could show
me how the pros do it yeah yeah brother
yeah [ __ ]
I ain't saying [ __ ] secret is you just
on say [ __ ] be cool bro okay Conrad okay
with everybody you're anxious innocent
okay you know how super [ __ ] loaded
so man it's not cool
don't make me regret letting you tag
along yeah breath no I ain't [ __ ]
all right amigo Calvary is almost here
whoo sorry I'm a little snappy I'm just
the new medical school would be
stressful you know total shocker
in fact [ __ ] sucks
can I imagine yeah I gotta be a good boy
to everybody talk increase increase
relationship increase ah I guess I keep
these in an undisclosed location yeah
lets you update it
I'll [ __ ] acts [ __ ] love me
man the graphics are [ __ ] insane
never pass finishing med school no but
it's just kind of a big life choice you
know I don't know what's the right thing
to do
okay I think at Brown go with your gut
if it's right no you know Oh Julie yeah
and all that kinda ready no like I'm
already I can tell you I don't brother
boo man it's gonna weird to cover his
face to face in the open yes what does
that mean yeah [ __ ] yeah love cracking
cold once especially with yet yeah cool
okay Conrad Conrad what's it gonna do
she barely [ __ ] did anything Church
updated relaxed
right on radical I like the cut of your
ship thank you oh that's [ __ ]
no actually never done it before
water virgin nice [ __ ] yeah then this
guy he's the [ __ ] worst [ __ ] just be
a dick to him holy [ __ ] bless that is
one hot tamale holy Toledo
but why
well hey I like check some things out
before we just [ __ ] go
[ __ ] dick thanks like [ __ ] lift
the anchor I'll tie the shatters yeah
that's it get it all out I laugh every
yeah you know maybe I should dick Milan
June 20th over here that's pretty far
out of the way I'm just thinking about
backup targets in case we don't find
anything on the dive cam listen to be
honest I've never heard of this wreck
you're looking for usually these things
are crawling with divers yeah this is
different I'm just saying if it gets too
late I know some nice places where you
can just take you know a nice dive Brad
did his homework if he says the wrecks
here it's here okay look you're the
client I'm just saying we don't have
unlimited daylight flick-flick [ __ ]
hates me
feast your eyes on this [ __ ] complain
calculations we're right on the money
always bet on brown kids a whiz we
should thank him
yeah now looks like world war two we are
ready to dive technically we should call
this in to port authorities as an
unreported direct technically are you
sure you don't want to do this the right
way
hey Cass [ __ ] I said I'm gonna say say
nothing guys no one knows no one cares
no harm no foul
okay the right way come on what is this
kindergarten I had to bring it up if we
just go down and take a look who's gonna
know fine as long as you're quick don't
touch anything
hey [ __ ] I just can't wait to be the
first one down there can you imagine I'm
touched get you guys in the water in a
few I'll set up the tanks the boys will
do the final checks take a look at the
camera see if you can find anything
useful right oh okay oh yeah he's like
[ __ ] dying yeah where's my [ __ ]
bro [ __ ] is he
where you at bro this
what's up are you doing sorry that
brewski got the better of me so good did
talk Hey all part of the adventure sorry
for putting a damper on things
no worries dude took more than that just
a script trip let's get some rest
come back when you feel better that's
guys look in fact I'm great
the [ __ ] we can't [ __ ]
we can't [ __ ] that's a that body oh yeah
oh yeah daddy shred of innocence oh
thank you I don't know how to write
oh whoa oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] now is that
the [ __ ] painting somebody look at
oh [ __ ] he's awakened I think wow I
don't know if I like it you can't have
premonitions like [ __ ] are they can I
have to it like [ __ ] real lifestyle
I'm just gonna just do it yeah that's
[ __ ] gamers I guess no that was
perfect
yeah just let it do its thing
yeah you know my dad
okay now I feel like a fool
releases the dubois 120
this doesn't look kosher
Teleco sure
expires no 31 maybe that's not kosher
does that mean [ __ ] missing something
[ __ ] well it's good let me see that that
gap
the [ __ ] is this
yeah that I got baby thanks a lot good
one
ii do this [ __ ] way cooler than a
regular scuba setup it's all that co2
that you'd normally just exhale into the
water and instead it gets totally reused
then it reduces decompression time on
your way up
[ __ ] yeah thanks for setting me straight
okay you little clown fishes I'm gonna
go see what this is up to you behave
Connie what's gonna [ __ ] wear it again
what is that
what is that the bank what the [ __ ] is a
bank stick on a shark
maybe we can fire it up again tonight
for our private post diet special are
you gonna bring your bang stick that
front cabin is gonna pop its portholes
oh [ __ ] yeah
let's do this batch
now check the thing I got the bank's
tech as it said darker absolutely plain
shape
it's pretty intact - this is a [ __ ]
remarkable fine let's move around a
little and find a way I love when they
say things like that
howdy captain you fancy a pint with your
second-in-command
you are not my second in command third
in command no fresh into your cabin
Bulls Dillon oh your well-paying
dashingly handsome seafaring client its
requesting the pleasure of your company
over a frosty amber liquid all right I
better not
[ __ ] loves it [ __ ] she like [ __ ]
like good nuts now we're together it's a
long story
it's complicated and it's really
difficult to explain well I'm a
complicated guy try me well it involves
at least several trips to the bank and
signing a big stocks of paper who with
large numbers on them though you took
out alone know you're smarter than you
look
if you're interested maybe my family can
make an investment in your business what
does that mean that's very kind of you
to offer I suppose we could have that
conversation the [ __ ] does that mean
something's beeping what's she doing
the [ __ ] was the watching is clear the
[ __ ] was the be Valen [ __ ] drunk
[ __ ] drunk as a skunk
okay
what the [ __ ] okay
look at this any different
I wish you what the [ __ ] this guy's up
down she like [ __ ] still alive how's
it going knocked out by cold frosty man
I feel like such a wimp
you're a [ __ ] lamp that hey it's your
vacation do it I am officially starting
a temperance Club party of one lifetime
membership hope the lovebirds are having
the time of their lives down there
concern I hope they know what they're
doing down there
attitude matters twenty meters down Alex
place the goof but he was pretty serious
about acing is a diving certification
hmm what other dyes have they done when
I got the booking I thought they were
newbies Alex and Julia have both locked
plenty of dives I'm the real amateur but
I'm ready okay gotta get back up check
you later
wait someone's [ __ ] glow in there for
a second it was like right over here I
figure this
Wow they're gonna [ __ ] take the boat
of it if she doesn't pair of [ __ ]
loans deuce or some [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] just check everything else
before Gantt with this guy alright let's
take a look at say what we got out here
all right shout out here what's this
sure here [ __ ] sludge
mm see what this is
talk to Alex Duke - Julia okay
let's see what he's bitching up to I
guess isn't a live feed I guess that
wouldn't like see him [ __ ] hang
[ __ ] how am I supposed to be doing
whether looks clear
yes
hey there how's it hanging it's hanging
very well
you look like you're taking full
advantage of your relaxation time a man
of many talents
the [ __ ] these people what's that about
that is not the Coast Guard so we're not
under arrest
how should we handle this get some guns
breath this feels off just be quiet and
don't say anything stupid okay where are
these [ __ ]
hey get out of here
what do you think you're doing
we [ __ ] ran a brand to us [ __ ] high
well shoot you you think it's more like
30 I can do 30 his eyes fall out
[ __ ]
they still [ __ ] download in
that was like talk to each other right
holy Toledo
[Music]
Conrad said one of the pictures showed
an opening Conrad really really the rear
turret oh good on you commie
six to our baby
let's [ __ ] that
see I press X real quick
ladies first
[Music]
can I just take a second to say holy
[ __ ] I like so we did it I mean can you
believe it
that [ __ ] that that protei
better better better [ __ ] yelling
there something Julia leave it you'll
have to take your gear off to give them
they're not worth it
Matt worth it Brad what if you get stuck
without your rebreather
maybe it is kind of dangerous absolutely
that better tie
[ __ ] hole in there
bullet halls all down the fuselage
Brad's gonna flip when he sees this
prejudices god they're mad
it seems [ __ ] hitch check it out they
reconfigured the bomb wrap to hold
lifeboats interesting one of the rescue
boats is missing I think they were using
it
what's snail's [ __ ] Co real
it's that bowtie
something you're gonna get that breath
gonna [ __ ] bite you
see me a jump-scare for sure
so we just [ __ ] leave now
I'm [ __ ] dark
if I could get out of here
I guess we're just going all the way in
[ __ ] queues [ __ ] about
alright go back in I guess right now bad
I said where you go better for days [ __ ]
wait that's it we use it up already
yes sir a [ __ ] pistol oh [ __ ] esting
and co-pilot gotta be
it's [ __ ] it what the [ __ ] no don't
[ __ ] touch than that
there's no choice but the [ __ ] touch
that
why why is she doing it hey why did you
do that
and that like that he did that
okay [ __ ] cow [ __ ] well it's a great
week sharp let's go Oh [ __ ] darkest
[ __ ] but then didn't know it was the
right time I guess no time great time
holy [ __ ] I know you can't tell cuz
we're underwater but about my knees
right now huh [ __ ] yeah yes
let's see excited coming it's gonna wear
outfits man but I like speed a little
wet Conrad so Kai rats clothes - Randy -
Jesus Christ
yeah
[Music]
with this is Julia we're coming back up
over
did that they're out that up there wait
Julia decompress here we we have to
decompress
let's decompress that's [ __ ]
say nothing just a few more seconds what
the hell happened it's cool then
everything's all right now
whoa there was a little mishap with the
barbecue Jesus look let the whole boat
was lit up
what's up with that other boat these
fishing guys came by and ran into the
dive line whatever who cares right what
I want exactly what you guys find well
we found the plate it's huge
full of cool stuff oh my god you guys
can you all just shut up for like one
second oh [ __ ] dude nicely done
come up and let's celebrate yeah yeah
we're celebrating tonight honey back you
know when I was am a little honeysuckle
you know and I'm saying that dude
well he's taking a lot of notes had idea
you're getting to know these intrepid
adventurers there Alex and his little
brother Brad trying to swim with the big
fish both seemed out of their day now
we're doing great
and Julia the love of Alex's life and he
the love of hers what about Conrad a
bold fellow you might say well maybe
you'd say arrogant and then there's
captain Flitz strong forthright stubborn
she appears somewhat immune to Conrad's
Charles so far at least let me reassure
you you've helped them to make some
decisions they'll value later on you're
doing well thank you
yeah well if their muchachos will end it
there